what is going on everybody and welcome
to part five of the deep learning with
python tensor board and care tensor
party tensor flow and Cara's tutorial
series
in this tutorial yes we are going to be
talking about tensor board specifically
what we're gonna be doing is talking
about how we can optimize models with uu
by using tensor board to kind of
visualize a bunch of different attempts
at models so with that let's go ahead
and get into it so looking at this model
right here what are some of the things
that you know we might want to test
because while we did pretty good like I
think we had like a 79 percent accuracy
or something like that that's not like
we should be able to do better than 79 I
think so what the things that we would
want to maybe start tweaking I mean
there's so many but we could change the
the optimizer within the optimizer the
learning rate we could change dense
layers whether we have them or we don't
we could change how many units per layer
that we want to have activation units we
also we don't need to make these the
same they could be different we could
change the kernel size we could change
stride which we haven't even touched and
the list goes on and on like decay decay
rate that kind of stuff well there's so
many things that we could test and if
you start multiplying like this many
things times this many things times like
you're looking at thousands of models so
what do you do so the easiest thing to
do in my opinion is start with the
easiest thing so the most obvious things
that we're going to tweak here are going
to be number of layers nodes per layer
and then basically you know do we have a
dense layer at the end or not so so
let's go ahead and try that so how might
we go about doing that well I'm gonna
comment this out just in case I
accidentally run it kill my kill my GPU
again I'm just going to import time here
and I'm just we're just gonna be kind of
coding something that I just kind of
just to exemplify and then we'll add it
to our script that looks ugly
anyways let's say we're gonna have some
choices of dead
Slayers like how many dense layers do we
want to have zero one or two then we're
gonna have layer layer sizes and then
again we're gonna do 32 64 64 and 128
why are we doing this so we've seen that
64 units per layer at least is somewhat
successful so once you get a model that
bites like a lot of times the first time
I train a model I'm not doing this
method I'm actually just kind of you
know hunt and pecking for anything that
will bite once I get something that
starts to at least learn a little bit
where and by learn either you know
accuracies going up or losses going down
once I get that then I'll go down to the
you know go down this road for this
process so in this case you know you in
theory you know you could try a model
with 16 nodes per layer 120 you know 32
64 128 256 512 1024 2048 but the problem
is this is gonna take forever so the way
that I do it is I'll just do one on each
side so 64 worked so let's try 32 and
then 128 and again these are just kind
of this is just kind of a convention
that people do you you you could do 30
6120 or 25 50 100 or whatever you want
to do you don't have to use the this you
know bits basically but anyway that's
just kind of what everyone does so
everyone does it so anyways just do one
thing on each side is my suggestion so
again one dense layer we found that zero
seemed to be better but we're gonna
really confirm that here one dense layer
at least works so now let's see what
happens maybe too dense layers that's
fairly common as well for people to put
rather than just one dense layer at the
end too dense layers at the end so we'll
do that and the final thing that we're
gonna do is con layers
how many convolutional layers do we want
what we don't want zero so we want one
we have found that two is successful and
then three so we'll do one two and three
now what we're gonna do is for you know
dense layer in
since layers then four layer size in
layer sizes for Kong layer in comm
layers so we're gonna iterate through
all these so three times three times
three
there's our models so what do we want to
do from this point basically first let's
do the motor important thing before we
forget and make the name so for the name
we're gonna say blank comm nodes dense
and then finally we'll do the the time
so this will be comped for mat-com layer
nodes was layer size and then dense is
dense layer and then finally int time
time okay so there is where we begin to
iterate through all the models so let's
go ahead and just print name save that
I'm gonna run it run this one in there
so I'm gonna open up console pi dash 3.6
tutorial cats and dogs and there we have
all of our names and model combinations
that we're gonna go with okay once we've
done that the next thing we're ready to
do is actually apply this to our model
itself so what we want to do is come
let's take I guess we'll just cut this
and then come up here delete come down
here where's our air just don't want to
forget that and then basically at this
point here we want to do the following
paste so we grab a new name just for
just to be sure let me get rid of this
name we should be redefining it but just
in case
name then we want to tab all this stuff
over okay so a few things we're gonna
have to take into consideration here
before you know at you know the first
layer needs to have the input shape so
no matter what we have to throw that in
then the other thing is the first dense
layer that we see has to have a
flattened so we have to consider all
those things so to handle for the conv
layers the first one is we just leave
this here then what we're gonna say is
4l in range
com layer minus one we're gonna do this
oh shoot I forget that how much forget
the sublime does that anyway don't
forget our : so for every convoy - one
because we've already got one here then
we're gonna do this stuff then we're
gonna do basically the exact same thing
for the dense layers so 4l in range of
dense layer this time we don't have to
do a minus one hold on I'm thinking
about one one thing I did was I threw
the flat no matter what after the
conflicts we're gonna flatten so what I
was doing is some redundant flattens but
I actually think second time going
through this what we could do every time
is just throw in a flatten because we
know we're either gonna do these dense
layers and then the output here or we're
gonna do zero dense layers but still
need to flatten before this one
this final dense like the output layer
just is a dense layer but what I mean by
dense layers is before the output layer
so I think this is actually this is a
way better idea I don't know why I
didn't think about this before so now
for LN dense layer we're just gonna do
model dot add and we're going to add a
dense layer of sighs well it's 64 but in
theory we're gonna use this layer size
parameter for the dense layer that's
another thing you probably wouldn't do
like you would have that those dense
layers different sizes
they're calm players because the Khans
layers that's not even real it's like
features it's totally different so you
need to have those be separate but I'm
just trying to show some examples here
so anyways layer size and then the
activation
we're just can use rectified linear
again great
and then finally you've got your last
dense layer and you're good to go now
the only other thing we need to do is
fix layer size here and here and now
we've got those you know three variable
parameters here and we are ready to
rumble so let me do this kind of clean
it up it looks good looks good let's
save it and I'm at least gonna start to
run it now this is a lot of models to
train so some people have been like yeah
that's taken forever well as probably
eyes are on the CPU version of
tensorflow
so if you're interested I'll put it well
there's two links in the text-based
version of this tutorial to the two
installation tutorials for I mean pull
up here so here is installing the CPU
and GPU version of tensorflow on Windows
and then I've also done it on a boon to
the process is identical you're gonna
need to do pip install tensorflow - GPU
you're gonna need to download and
install CUDA toolkit and then you're
gonna need to download an extract qu DNN
into the CUDA toolkit so that's gonna be
the same whether you're on Mac Linux or
Windows so anyways yeah but you can
check out those tutorials if you want
also you can check out paper space
that's who I use to put any models in
the cloud they've got a huge assortment
of GPUs and varying prices and really
arguably the best prices you can get on
GPUs still so I would definitely check
them out I'll put a link to them in the
description as well that's a referral
link you should get ten dollars and
credit I believe so lets you get you
started training your first model but I
wouldn't recommend wasting that on this
I'm just gonna I'll show you the results
okay you can also run this on your CPU
if you want but anyways so I just want
to make sure the code works right now so
I'm just going to go ahead and run it
and make sure this even works name is
not defined okay we need to throw the
tensor board into here let's see that's
exactly why I wanted to remove that name
because we were redefining it but that
was gonna be problematic okay let's try
that one now and come back over here
okay looks like it's learning looks like
is training good to go now luckily for
you guys I'm not gonna sit here and make
you guys wait for like you know 45
minutes to run through all these models
I'm actually just gonna break this I
have already done this so I am going to
close that and now I'm going to come
over let's see here
tensor tensor board longer equals a
bunch of logs then that'll take a moment
to fully load but soon we will get ooh
an error here I got some funky looking
error here I'm not really sure why I got
that hold on so this is what I'm
attempting a bunch of logs hmm this is
really unfortunate I wonder if it's
because I I don't know if they hard code
the names let me delete the old logs
back-end event bras cuz like maybe it
looked it logs the path I don't think
that's how that works but let me try to
just change this name back to logs
logged or logs hope no quotes don't
forget that I hope that's it I'm gonna
be really bummed if I lost all those
logs oh it still throws an error though
but this time at least loads that's
really curious lot of whites do it why
I'm just going to accept that key it's
almost like we've got two different
errors going on anyway I'm gonna so I
think what's happened is in the logs
I guess maybe in the event file it saves
that it's in path logs or something
because it wasn't finding any of them
this time it's just got a single key
error but that's not breaking anything
so I want to go ahead and continue on
rather than try to debug that one but
just know if you I guess if you save a
logged or remembered ringing it back I
guess I don't know I I swear I've done
this before anyway here they all are so
we can see them all and again you know
think this red one here whatever this
model is it's the one comm 32 nodes per
layer and one dense now one seems to not
be doing very well which is curious and
it's definitely not because it's just
one calm because we've got one convinced
128 nodes still on the map so not really
sure why why that one was no no bueno
anyway the path that I would take is you
know as I've said before come to
validation loss go to the end of
validation loss and look at the the best
ones so by far the best one is three
comm 128 zero so three convolutional
layers 128 nodes per layer no dense
layer the second best is three con 32
zero dense again and let me wonder if it
changes at all if we remove any of the
smoothing it doesn't appear to really
change okay anyways so 332 0 how about
the third best wait what was this one
threes
oh they did move so now the best one is
364 is 0 the second best is 332 0 and
then the third best is 3 120 and 0 so I
think we're starting to see a pattern
here 3 convolutional layers is the best
0 dense layers the best so so
immediately we know that now when we go
through our model like because because
in in this case all the nodes per layer
metrics were you know the best one was I
think it was 64 I forget now but 32 and
128 were also better than everything
else as long as you only had 3
three convolutional layers and zero
dents now one thing to keep in mind is
it might be the case that the dense
layer would be better off being a 512 or
a 256 so much larger dense layer like a
64 layer are 64 node dense layers
actually quite a small dense layer so it
could be the case that if we were to try
a 512 that that would actually beat the
the other sizes so the next thing you
could do is just test that so you could
say all right we're gonna go with 2
dense layers we'll go with 3 conv layers
and we'll just do 64 here and come down
here and in my I think the tensor board
only went to 10 epochs if I recall right
let's check it yeah 10 epochs so let's
just keep 10 instead and in this dense
layer what did we say dense layers
should be 1 I don't know why I said -
there's no sir
ok dense the layer sighs let's try
trying to side between 512 and 256 let's
do 512 just for kicks so we can save
that and then let's come up here PI - 3
6
we're gonna run tutorial cats dogs
trying to think do we hopefully I don't
have anything else in memory that's
gonna crash we will find out soon enough
okay and we're off and we did 512 dense
dense 512 3 con flares ok hopefully I
did that all right ok so the other thing
is let's untie GLE all the runs and
let's go with 3 comm 3203 coms 64 0 and
3 conf 128 0 and then at the very very
bottom this one right here should be our
new model that we're training so now let
me just refresh to get everything on the
screen
okay so here we can see how things are
going this gray line is the newest one
with the 512 dense layer so really this
otherwise should be compared I guess -
is it done yet no still going it's done
now though so compare that let's compare
that to the other 64 by 3 well first
let's just hit this should be done now
ok so at least in validation accuracy
and validation loss we can see it really
just died out here but it learned in
sample better so this tells us a couple
things one is this larger you know dense
layer really just helped us to memorize
our data which is no good because we can
see the actor so you just went through
the roof like basically if i refresh
this it almost looks like we might have
gotten a perfect score at least my notes
say 90s or the you know the log says 97
so 97 versus the validation accuracy of
82 definitely overfit especially you can
see it happened right here and you can
almost watch it tick down right here
like you can see where the loss rate
almost like hinges right here down so
that tells you so for some reason at
that point the models like ah I'll just
memorize everything with this giant
layer so anyways that's a lot of stuff
that we've kind of gone through but now
the next step would be okay now that we
know that at least we'll go at zero
dense three convolutional layers and
probably will go with one of these these
are these about this validation loss is
kind of sketchy on all three so I might
if it was me I might actually keep all
three of these to go forward but I'd
probably stop changing conv layers and
dense layers I'd probably leave dense at
zero now what you find here with this
confident won't necessarily apply to
other data sets so in this case this is
a really easy thing for a model to learn
cuz it's a binary choice but if you had
something like m missed or something
even more complex with like object
detection or something
this model is probably actually not big
enough to even learn
so you'd want a bigger model and then
the dense layer adding a dense layer
might actually help rather than just
help you memorize so just keep that in
mind
no to you know even just image operation
types of tasks even if it's a binary
choice note or is the same especially
like the adding this dense layer would
actually probably help if we had more
samples like in this case I think we got
like what was it twenty five thousand or
something images which isn't very much
if we had five hundred thousand images
probably this dense layer wouldn't be
able to memorize things it wouldn't be
large enough of a network to memorize
and instead it would only help so every
time you have a new challenge you're
probably you don't have to go through
this operation over again but I see all
the time people are like how do you know
what size ball you don't you it's all
trial and error and you tweak things and
you basically perform your own
optimization algorithm on the models you
make little tiny tweaks in both
directions see where that takes you and
then you keep repeating that process
over again
so and that's why things take so long
like that's why the Python plays GTA
series took forever to progress because
you've got to do these like incremental
changes and then when the model itself
already takes like a week to train that
becomes very challenging now obviously
some things are very important like
rectified linear is pretty good but if
you've got you know like understanding
what kind of output or what kind of
activation layers to use like do you
have negative data the other thing is
like you know you always want to scale
your data you want to take those things
into into consideration and that it can
help to some degree to understand like
how do activation functions work so you
can understand maybe that you should use
a different one in certain circumstances
or something like that but for the most
part this is how you do it and in fact
this method here this has been what I've
been using for quite a while but
recently I was looking at like a talk
from somebody from tensorflow and they
did the exact same the exact same thing
I figured somebody from Google would
probably have a better method than this
but no so this is what even the pros are
doing so anyways
that's all for now if I've glossed over
something you've got questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you guys
in the next tutorial I don't really know
what the next one will be I still would
like to cover recurrent Nets in this
little series and there's like a few
other things I wouldn't mind covering
and I can't really decide if I want to
do more like this kind of stuff where
it's like the kind of the API is helping
you understand your model so things like
check you know automated checkpoints and
stuff like that or go into recurrent
Nets and stuff like that also I've seen
some questions about like AMD GPUs no
you can't do that with PI torch also
I've seen lots of requests for pi torch
I see you guys I'm aware of PI torches
existence let me tell you what I think
of pi torch so let's just go to Google
I'm gonna type PI torch examples I'm
gonna click on their github 4 PI torch
examples and this over here and let's go
to NS because we've seen an EM nest data
set let's go to main alright here we are
on an official example ok clearly this
is like your model I get it alright so
you've got one con flare to convalesce
you've got a dropout that's the other
thing we didn't even talk about but you
you would start to add drop out like and
again drop out will will help you
against over fitment so if we added like
a 20 30 percent drop out especially at
the end of this dense layer that would
help the model to not over fit and that
might actually give us even better
accuracy so that'd be something worthy
of checking let's see model dot add let
me just add it real quick I don't know
if we've droop out add drop out I think
I can do this I think that's that's the
right syntax we'll find out soon enough
let me just run that real quick as I go
back and complain about PI torch so many
ways
there's your your model and you've got
like you know the I guess as it goes
forward now you've got your your
activation functions come in at this
stage ok then here's your training where
you're gonna it's kind of
you know the thing is kind of here
compile so what optimizer are we gonna
use and also this is I guess where you
pass in data and target and then here's
how you test the things and then this I
can't really fault it because it's just
a command line or you know interface but
look at this code this is ugly this
reminds me of like everyone's like oh
it's more pythonic this reminds me of
like base raw tensorflow
so if anybody knows a you know an API
that sits on top of pi torch I'd love to
look into it
but I have no interest in going back to
the raw you know coding the the models
in a much lower level manner it just
involves too much room for error and I
just don't see the argument for pi torch
I just don't get it
so if you're one of these PI torch
people tell me why PI torch I just don't
get it I just don't I don't want to
write this code anymore I'm really
enjoying chaos and I feel like I did my
time writing raw tensorflow
okay so our model is done and let's go
to h pc i don't know what i did with the
other tensor board it does not look like
it did any better well we'll see in fact
let's just on toggle Oh
so this should be the latest one and
then let's just do like three three two
zero so validation accuracy it was
actually better until right at the very
end and the validation loss looks pretty
good too let's let's pop up the other
three and then where's 3 128 okay cool
so the orange one validation accuracy
law so it's pretty good it's pretty
comparable with the drop out but still I
think you'd probably you would just want
more data
anyways that's enough for now questions
comes turns complaints you don't like
what I just said about pied torch leave
it below otherwise I will see you guys
in another video also let me know what
you want to see do you want to see more
of like the API type stuff like tensor
board do you want to see more
information on tensor board because
there's all kinds of visualizations that
we can actually do intensive word was
kind of cool
or do you want to see more like models
and things being applied to things and
all that so anyways let me know down
below otherwise I will see you guys in
another hopefully much shorter video